I get this text message with a very
weird audio clip of my friend telling me
that he's obsessed with Joe Biden
and just like what are you what is this
it's like not a very political guy and
then he sends me a link to elevenlabs.io
where you can add anyone's voice I've I
I put my voice in and I'll just leave it
at this I don't want to name anybody
because I don't want to I don't this is
a creepy thing but there are a variety
of different podcast hosts I've uploaded
I took a sample of their voice okay and
I was able to deep fake their voice in
two seconds I'm not exaggerating I
clicked add voice drag and drop MP3
thumb snap and it does it so so first
I'll show you this this is speech
synthesis from 11 labs this is their
generic atom it's what their their
default is I typed in this is not a real
person talking it's a deep fake let's
generate see what it sounds like
we need volume is do we have volume it's
generating that's what takes time cool
yeah you gotta give it a second this is
so freaky I heard my own voice earlier
today and we're gonna play your voice
this is not a real person talking it's a
deep fake let's try that again this is
not a real person talking it's a deep
fake there you go so you can type in
basically anything and um when I first
heard this I went that's really cool
I've heard robot voices before I'm not
super concerned about it right but then
we decided to uh
oh which one should I play
here we go hi I'm Luke rodowski and I
know how to pronounce my own last name
that's Seamus Coughlin by the way well
it's a deep fake of Sheamus Coughlin of
Sheamus that's Sheamus that's Luke that
sounded like Sheamus that was Luke play
that again
hi I'm Luke rodowski and I don't know
how to pronounce my own last name I'm
gonna go with Sheamus I think that's
Luke hey what's up guys I'm Ian
Crossland and I'm not wearing any pants
today that sounds like Chris Poole no
that I love that guys that sounded just
like and I'm not wearing any pants today
ever ever I really like that guy that
does suck it's really great just like
bringing a piece to the Middle East yup
um you gotta let it play Ian Trump he's
the best president ever
I really like that guy he's like you
just gotta lay really great things like
bringing peace to the Middle East
um
so we have a whole bunch of different uh
uh should I play yeah it's so weird
because I guess I'm not responsible for
what comes out of that guy's mouth
dude don't tell Wesley I told you this
but we kissed last night I think we're
in love I do love Wesley by the way but
not like that so I don't want to play
other people's voices that aren't
affiliated with this company or the show
okay but um let me just tell you name
your favorite high-profile personality
it is freaky good you said some of them
you got that all those voice clips from
One MP3 that you that you sent the
machine
I took like five to ten seconds of
different people's voices
uploaded it there was no right five to
ten seconds there was no rendering time
it's amazing no rendering time you just
upload it and then I pressed the
rendering is when you type in the text
and we were able to make Ian say a whole
bunch of stuff and uh did you try your
voice my voice didn't work
do you have an example what no why would
that be because it wasn't I have no idea
it wasn't able to do it I I put in a a
not that large of a file because 10
megabytes is the maximum
and what came out sounded just kind of
like someone trying to impersonate Me by
talking quickly but it didn't sound like
me okay and my brother tried it didn't
work on him either so I'm good I'm glad
about that by the way but um this really
freaked me out because wow some of the
voices we were able to generate and
again the reason I'm not naming these
people because you have to imagine what
it would be like if someone were to play
your voice right it is freaky so what's
the upshot of all of this so we have
there's no upshot we have like someone I
mean there's like so once we have
everybody's voice and deep porn and like
all of this stuff how are you ever going
to tell somebody who you are as opposed
to the the fake you is people are going
to
take the voice of a famous actress and
they're going to put it in this and
they're gonna generate her saying things
like I love you sure I will marry you oh
you're a dream come true
yes exactly that's the vanilla version
then they're gonna put their face on the
body of course and they're gonna put the
VR headset on and that's where we're
headed that's exactly so real life and
now imagine Nora link where you can
actually trigger sensory perception so
now people are just telling the machine
create for me celebrity X and run our
honeymoon wink wink you know where this
is going and then well you wouldn't even
have to say wink wink you would just do
the thing to the audience here I get it
you get it what concerns me I think what
you're mentioned earlier people do weird
stuff when them by themselves like how
the AI doesn't understand context like
humans do so if if the creator of the
program wants to alter the definition of
a word you're like I want to go out for
a horse ride with my favorite and
they're like okay change what it means a
horse means slightly and like there's no
no way to context could the AI not like
look at all horses across all time and
and decide what a horse is yeah that
that's what I mean by curve fitting it
can kind of generate
um
a general image of a horse it can even
uh look at particular aspects of horses
and and do that it just doesn't
understand what it really is yeah and it
can't deliver that thing that is like
reality even with neurolink I think it
won't be able to quite do that well
that's what um I think Cipher said in
Matrix the reason everything tastes like
chicken Cipher said that right right
everything tastes like chicken because
the robots didn't know what they didn't
know what it tastes like yeah so the
thing then becomes too who's going to
maintain the machine
like that's that's the ethical AI
question
this was um I talked about this on the
show a bit my my Sci-Fi TV show idea
I'll give you the simple version did you
hear me talk about this before I have
yes go ahead so the general idea is it's
like the last city on earth and for some
reason the world is disrepair and
destroyed it's post-apocalyptic nobody
in the last City knows why there's like
maybe like 10 10 million people and so
they sent out scouting parties one day a
scouting party comes across strange
slender humanoid beings super thin and
tall in like Chrome suits that have
advanced technology that just wipe them
out and kill them and then the central
conflict is between these groups the
humans think these are aliens that came
and wiped out all of humanity the end of
the season is the Revelation and it's
like if this would ever to be made a
show totally be ruined by me telling us
but the Revelation is that these are
actually humans and what happened is
around the end of the 20 the the 2000s
2099 or whatever humans began rapidly
migrating to pods with norlink just like
how cell phones were adopted in a matter
of a year or two right everybody had one
sure everybody eventually switches to
the digital economy and lives in pods
where all of their desires are
maintained so all the cities start
falling into disrepair because the only
thing you need to maintain pain is the
machines that have feeding tubes into
people's bellies like the Matrix to keep
them alive as they experience Paradise
however they want right but periodically
Scout groups have to go out to maintain
the machine refuel it
humans who did not go into these systems
don't know what happened because think
about it this way if you're trying to
understand the world right now but did
not have the internet would you know
what was going on no you'd have very
little idea exactly right so if all news
migrates to the metaverse right and the
people who outside of it don't have
access to it people who refuse to join
for religious reasons or because they
lived in the middle of nowhere and
didn't have strong internet just didn't
care so this is like so the city as it
exists in your scenario is like a few
Generations down the road a few
Generations after so like 21 for the Pod
thing yeah so there's no records right
they're they're on they're going online
and they're like for some reason all
internet records just cease around this
point and newspapers stop getting
printed something wiped out Humanity we
don't know what but it's not that they
got wiped out it's that they're like
they migrated right they migrated to a
place where they were not they weren't
interacting anymore with right now
people in cities a lot of them have cell
phones you can you still know people
exist in cities you can still get a
newspaper you can still drive to the
city but if everybody left the city went
underground into a pod to live forever
you would never see them all you would
know is one day you walked into the City
and there were very few people this is
where the machine stops the EM Forester
Novella was written in what 1911. but
everybody goes underground yeah
everybody goes underground and they are
fed and cared for by the machine
um and they they basically like mating
happens by Machine hookups uh and all of
this stuff and then um the machine it
stops
stops 100 years later and then a whole
bunch of wacky stuff happens people are
being born in pods who've never
experienced the real world and will
never leave and there's only specially
designated humans who are reality Scouts
to make sure the machine is functioning
who go out periodically with advanced
technology because once everyone's in
the machine scientific simulation is
rapid and exponential with all the power
of the AI that they have so then they
have automation which can synthesize and
replicate and Advance Beyond people who
live outside the machine we're looking
at a situation where we're going to have
neural link we're going to have all
these deep fakes and whatnot so that you
can create your own reality inside your
own pod and we're going to have world
government that keeps us specifically
from moving around so that we don't mess
up the environment you'll own nothing
and be happy we'll own nothing will be
in our you could be in it right now
we'll have no freedom of movement you
could be in it right now for all you
know and then you're going to have like
one person who's you know yeah who's uh
who's Winston in 1984 or the
um the the Sun character in the machine
stops or K in the trial or the castle
you know you're gonna have this guy
who's just like looking around trying to
figure it out you're in it right now
well I don't know right now you wouldn't
know have any of you seen like a classic
sci-fi film called Forbidden Planet from
the 1960s no it's about a civilization
that did this essentially they created
machines that could satisfy their every
desire merely with mental mental
stimulus and they developed a from that
machines that had out near infinite
power
um it just you know in the 1960s all
that all happened on Mars right and
um so you uh you find out that they
destroyed themselves towards the end of
this movie because what they didn't
count on was the ID
the monsters from the ID the
subconscious mind began to make another
reality a terrifying reality
that destroyed them
because one of the things that in such a
world where you're in a pod and you can
make any world your unconscious mind
could take control
and build things in the AI that you
don't necessarily want
and I always remembered that phrase from
that movie the monsters from the ID
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time